now if they go cream right do you do you
how do y'all do it y'all do stove y'all
do like bar like not barbecue but like
luau style how do y'all do it no it's
more of a
it's there's a cream the crematory has
this chamber
that you put the body in and that's how
the body's cremated
and is it briquettes or wood like what
is in there do you know no it's gas
oh damn because it has to be pre it's
preheated to about 1400 degrees before
the body goes in
and do you put the body in there no i've
got somebody else that does that
okay and is that a trustworthy person
usually that person to me seems
shady yeah no that's that's a very
trustworthy person
wow because i just can't i mean if i
and how long does it take to really
grill somebody down
most of the time it depends upon the the
size of the person
and how new the crematory is like a
grandparent though how much you think oh
you know you're probably
you're probably a little over an hour
damn
and what about like a oh what about that
600 pounder
now see that's different because
you think of somebody that's 600 pounds
and the fat that's on oh yeah
that becomes a controlled grease fire
so it's there are the crematories have
weight limits on them
so some crematories can only do 500
pounds
some of them can only do like 700 pounds
some of them are rated for a thousand
and so you have to you have to make sure
that
you don't get somebody too large yeah
for that for that crematory because
otherwise you can get a prop
you can have a major problem one of my
friends
who was um who had a crematory he was
cremating somebody and he didn't realize
that they were
as obese as they were and so
he had a grease fire going you couldn't
tell it from inside
but the crematory was smoking and
they're not supposed to smoke because
the afterburner is supposed to be
burning off all that smoke
well he was in downtown in a city and
rolling black smoke he gets a call from
the funeral home
and when he just said it to cook and
left he's like no he was he was sitting
inside the building with the crematory
oh and so he was sitting inside in there
you know he didn't notice
and he didn't he couldn't see all the
smoke outside and he gets a call from
probably a native american i guess
hey man i got some rough signals rolling
up
but it was but the funeral home was
actually across the street from the
crematory
and somebody from the funeral home
called and said what's going on over
there
you're rolling a lot of smoke well about
the same time that they called
the fire department showed up and the
fire department had to come
that well the fire department came
because there's all this smoke
and it it wasn't anything that needed
the fire department
but they but they just showed up wow so
needless to say he learned a lot that
day
dang so so because the body what it's
just it's just like having uh yeah my
sister sometimes her and her husband
will make um
cracklings you know they'll make
cracklings in the yard and they'll cut
up all the fat and put it in this big
open thing
and somebody's got to be right there
with like a boat or just kind of hitting
it every now and then
once they put the body in the cream
until in the end of the crematorium
into the furnace do they kind of hit it
with a thing every now and then or they
just
it's one time it's kind of just you know
starting
and close the door no it's kind of start
and close the door and then
and then of course they'll run it
through you know
to grind up the bones and everything
that don't burn down
so there's a grinder in there too well
no the grinders after they pull the
cremains out
okay so you put that body in you grill
them down
you know and can you do well done can
you do rare it's just one oh no it's
just one setting
okay damn one setting you can't you
can't get a medium rare person yeah
that's what i would go something a
little bit more you know uh
ceviche or something something that's
quite so fine
yeah i want to be a little grainy you
know um
so once they get that bone and
everything else burns down
you know they they take and what doesn't
burn down they run through that
kind of grinder and you know to where
they can make it real fine
okay and depending upon depending on
what crematory you use and what kind of
grinder they've got
some cremains are finer than others
really
so who who's more of a fine or creme
maine like what are you talking about
like a japanese guy
no no it's it's just you know because a
lot of times there's companies that own
these cr
crematories so that you don't have so
every funeral home doesn't have to own
one
there's like a third party guy that has
this crematory and you take your body
there
and you know they'll go for it for you
and so
some of those guys you know if they have
newer stuff
it might be finer than the olders you
know
if they're running that push mode yeah
yeah yeah totally man
yeah yeah every now and then you got
somebody who just you know they haven't
sharpened the silverware in a while
exactly exactly like them what do y'all
cremating this thing with spoons
one thing that one thing about the
cremation process that you'll find
interesting
yeah if somebody has a pacemaker
that has to be removed before cremation
because that battery will explode no and
that bat
and if that battery explodes it can
actually ruin
the chamber that they use for the
cremation wow
it's like when some [ __ ] would throw
a can of wd-40 in a ditch fire when i
was growing up oh yeah
everybody's out there that cat a
hairspray yeah look at that white rain
somebody whip a can of white rain yeah
that projectile's coming at you dude
somebody's going down man
that's when you just let the lord work
man that was kind of like a rural
version of russian roulette man
everybody's out there somebody's cooking
a wiener a couple kids are just running
just jumping through the fire you notice
little evil knives
and then some a-hole just uh just
freaking just flips a can of uh
aqua net into that bastard that's right
and you know somebody's
it's it's just pure luck from there on
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah